thank you
a new Prince and Princess of Wales same
William and Kate this week is Showcase
for where they still want to make a
difference mindful of how their new
roles have come about am I much missed
grandmother who cares so much for the
natural world
in times of loss it is a comfort to
honor those we miss through the work we
do
a message of continuity but will being
aired to the throne bring more
constraints Lord William Hague has
worked with the prince for eight years
we're not changing tone you know if
anything we're going up another gear so
of course we have to take great care
with the issues that we work on but
there is no shortage of those issues
um that it's absolutely right for a
royal family that's engaged with the
world and wants to help people and serve
people to get involved with outwardly
there is this sense of carrying on as
normal and doing everything possible to
respect the queen but with new titles
inevitably become more responsibilities
and new expectations
and that's not just to do with their
charity work but also how family life is
going to fit in with it all so both
privately and officially with the king
and queen consort really needing support
from both William and Kate
certainly her popularity could be vital
for the monarchy she is very aware of
the weight of being a new Princess of
Wales and following Diana where she
really wants to make her own impact is
getting more support for families
as they try to give their own children a
more normal life they know that doing
what they want can bring criticism
in 2016 Emily Andrews wrote a story
claiming William was work shy a position
taken by the Sun newspaper when he'd
been doing funeral engagements and
flying the air ambulance
to be fair he took it on the chin at
least publicly with me
and he said that it was fair enough but
there was a lot of things we hadn't seen
behind the scenes that's the point about
William I think he has been on a journey
with the press in his public persona
he cares very much
about how he's portrayed in the Press
make no mistake even if he
gives off the impression that he doesn't
he can't control everything
as they found in Belfast
but I'm told the King has been mindful
of preparing William like involving him
in meetings for the duchy of Cornwall
the land and businesses that fund the
air
under the queen change was often subtle
never sudden a tradition it seems her
family are now Keen to preserve if the
more questioning world around them is
going to allow it Rhiannon Mills Sky
News